[Music]
this is my first
rstudio conf though i've been wanting to
come for at least the last
several years or come to a r studio
event
i also feel a little bit of like an
imposter
so i apologies for that i'm i'm here
mostly to talk about the great work that
folks here have done
and also how it integrates with the the
tensorflow ecosystem and what we have
coming down the pipe
so i i full disclosure i am a python
person
though i love r desperately and i
uh prior to going to google i did r
every single day working as a machine
learning engineer at chevron and at
microsoft
so so like i said i'm very excited
to be here and if you have questions
also very happy to answer them either
about the tensorflow roadmap about
functionality about what
exactly tf autograph and tf function are
doing
etc so tensorflow 2 what is new what
have we been up to for the last year and
what do we have planned for next year
so as mentioned in the previous
presentation
the biggest release that we had was
focused on tensorflow 2. and tensorflow
2 was a move
for eager execution so opposed to this
like
a very complicated notion of building
computation
graphs um in a static way you suddenly
get dynamic computational graphs
um so you can do uh crazy things
like add two numbers together and
immediately get a response
right like so uh so the the same kind of
pythonic way that we like to do things
um with scikit-learn or with r and
carrot uh you could start doing with
tensorflow
um we've also added a number of
additional uh
sort of products throughout the
tensorflow ecosystem many of which are
fast accumulating
our equivalents so today for example we
announced on the tensorflow blog
that there's something nifty called
keras tuner that does automated hydro
parameter tuning there is an r
equivalent
as of i think four hours ago yesterday
at noon so so you can go and check it
out as well we should be featuring it on
the tensorflow blog in the next couple
of days
so yes that is uh that is
tensorflow in a nutshell the topics that
we're going to
cover today are fully dynamic layers and
models with keras as well as model
subclassing
the built-in hyper-parameter tuning with
keras tuner
and then also custom training loops and
i think
also it's a little bit important to take
a step
back how many folks in the room
are doing machine learning today like
for your day job
lots of hands and then how many of you
are using
tensorflow for deep learning within
those machine learning jobs
excellent i'm assuming that everyone
else is using
kind of more traditional r packages like
forecast or
carrot or those things of that nature
and and i think that's that's awesome
in the sense that for most sort of data
science and machine learning tasks
um explainability is is super important
and a lot of great business problems can
be solved
using more traditional methods and they
don't really need
kind of the hammer that is deep learning
to go about solving them
but for the tasks that deep learning is
great for
there really is no comparison so you can
see a few examples on the screen here
if you haven't taken a look at some of
the demos that you can do with things
like tensorflow or pytorch recently
uh there are things like object
detection where you can
input an image and immediately get a
sort of a bounding box
with a confidence level for different
kinds of objects
or you can sort of do automatic
speech transcription where you have an
audio file and
text is automatically generated from it
or you can do
text generation where you have an input
sentence and then suddenly a
a completely reasonable additional
second paragraph is added
right so these are things that seem like
science fiction
um but they're really straightforward to
do with existing
deep learning models many of which have
been open sourced and are freely
available
so you saw before an example of tf hub
tf hub is a collection of models that we
use internally at google
so those examples that i was telling you
about before with speech transcription
um with object detection with a sort of
image captioning where you
input an image and it automatically
generates a sentence describing what's
in the image
without you having to do any training
whatsoever
this is a model that's freely available
for you to use
all of those are available for free at
tfhub.dev
they are all in saved model format and
they're all usable
within the within the r ecosystem
so those are just some of uh some of the
examples
of things that you can do with deep
learning
that would take either a whole bunch of
hard coding
or a whole bunch of very specific uh
very specific logic
if you were if you were going to go
about doing them with either plain our
code or with
traditional machine learning methods so
tensorflow too
the official release is available today
tensorflow 2.1 gives you support on tpus
and all of it's available within the r
ecosystem so if you install the
tensorflow r package
or if you're using anaconda on windows
you can do install underscore tensorflow
and you're kind of off to the races and
what this gives you
is pretty much everything that you would
everything that you would need to get
started with doing deep learning in the
traditional keras interface
i also want to make sure to recognize
the great work that cigarette has been
doing
um if you haven't taken a look at the
tensorflow r studio blog
it is the coolest thing in the world um
and it's also really interesting to see
like every
uh every day a new blog post is released
it gets circulated almost immediately
especially among the tf probability team
and everybody everybody has a sort of
excellent feedback
about the our documentation the r blog
posts
often the our documentation is better
than the tensorflow python documentation
which is again really cool to see
so deep learning tensorflow 2 is a
perfect
time to get started partially because of
this eager execution business that i was
telling you about before
but also because the ecosystem is is
sort of brain
bogglingly large so so to show you this
um and hopefully okay cool i still have
miss green that's nice
um so if you go to github.com
tensorflow tensorflow um what you'll see
is that as part of the tensorflow
organization
we have a collection of 92 repositories
and each one of those repositories is a
project
so tensorflow probability would be one
tensorflow hub
is one you can see things like tf agents
the tf model garden repo that we're
building out
we have a project using swift language
bindings tensorboard
model analysis fairness indicators so
building a collection of tools that you
can use to make sure that your machine
learning models
are are sort of responsibly and
ethically
making their assessments and their
classifications
as well as add-ons support for
tensorflow.js pretty much anything that
you could possibly imagine
we use tensorflow extensively at google
in every single one of our products
so bert for example was just recently
rolled out to pretty much
everything that i use at least on a
daily basis
so gmail you know
docs sheets etc
and so if you if you want something
that's production
tested and battle hardened
it'd be hard to find an equivalent so
tensorflow one with the python
implementation was using wonky things
called sessions
we've learned a lot since then sessions
were a little bit frustrating
i'm not sure how many people in the
audience are familiar with python code
but the way that the logic for this
worked was that you would define some
variables
but you wouldn't be able to use them
immediately you would have to initialize
something called a session
you would have to then initialize the
variables you would have to start a
queue runner to be able to even
understand
what this input data would look like you
would have to create these weird batch
sticks
and it just felt like a very wonky
experience
the transition from tensorflow 1 is
using keras as the recommended high
level api
every single addition that we make to
the tensorflow ecosystem going forward
is going to be keras focused so i think
tf the text pre-processing layers was
mentioned in the previous talk
we're going to also see keras
integration with something called
tensorflow extended
so all of the tooling there will be
supported as well
and you'll still be able to use low
level operations
so so if you need the the kind of close
to the machine
manipulation you can use that as well
and like i said you can do crazy things
like add numbers together
we've also removed duplicate
functionality we are trying to make
consistent and intuitive syntax across
the apis
um so again focusing on keras is the
standard interface
and creating compatibility throughout
the entire tensorflow ecosystem with
something called saved model
and you are able to output saved models
with all of your our tensorflow code
um so flexibility the raw ops
follower of a low level api um and it's
all with one api
so just like tensorflow live keras uh we
also love rnr studio
um and so uh the majority of the
development work that's been done to
date
on our themed packages has been done by
the
the great team here and i
am very interested in finding out how we
can better collaborate
with both our users and the people who
are creating tensorflow
are packages we're starting something
this year called
tensorflow for data science so
building out building out a collection
of products
that if you aren't necessarily the kind
of folks
who who want to be sort of generating
novel model architectures from scratch
but you do want to be solving
kind of the world's problems in an
applied machine learning setting
how can we build better tooling for that
and that's partially python but it's a
huge portion of our users as well
so be on the lookout for more
information about
tensorflow for data science
and then also keras the python
implementation
looks quite a lot like the rstats
implementation
you might see you might see a few
a few pipes but the
for the most part it looks pretty
similar
so technical differences in tensorflow
2.
we have something called the symbolic
api as well as the imperative api
and the difference between um the
difference between the two
is is kind of uh it isn't immediately
obvious
right so if you're doing um if you're
using the keras functional api
your model turns into byte code whereas
sequential api your model's more
graph of layers and mixing functionality
between the two is not
at all recommended so
if you if you are are intending to use
uh the the keras api i strongly suggest
sticking with one
um and and sort of staying with it
for training loops and for uh for kind
of understanding the differences between
the different keras implementations
um you might have heard of standalone
keras historically
that has since ceased development um so
now
all development work on keras is
sort of supporting the tensorflow api
back end
there's still the the sort of historic
implementation that supports things like
theano and cntk
but for the most part all development
for keras is going to be focused on
tensorflow
going forward um and then the the keras
our bindings for tf keras are created by
the good folks here at our studio
um and they i believe they are focused
more on the the tf keras implementation
as as opposed to the historic keras
implementation
so building pipelines with tf data sets
is like you would you would use
pretty much the same style of interface
that you've focused on before
so i actually i have a question
for for folks in the audience
how many of you have used tf datasets
before
a couple excellent so so
the reason the reason why tf datasets
exists
is because if you have if you have a
sort of complex performance hardware
architecture so if you have gpus or if
you have tpus or tpu pods that you're
attempting to saturate
you can't really do that with uh sort of
the
the
common um numpy interface or the
traditional data data pumping formats
um that you see today so tf data kind of
gives you the ability to
build high performant data input
pipelines
using just python as opposed to having
to hand roll these
input streams in c plus plus or
something
something a little bit more at least to
me
a little bit more frightening so
so tf data is a sort of a platform
agnostic
uh data input pipeline that you could
use with tensorflow
but also if you have our code that you
do want
you know a different r package that does
need a similar pipeline structure
for its work you could use tf data sets
for that as well
you could also use it for things like
jacks
or if you if you wanted to try that out
or even other sort of competing machine
learning frameworks
i i do think that it's the best sort of
performant data input pipeline
that is available for specifically for
tensorflow
and for jacks right now
so so that is tf data
um moving along
um compatibility with the tensorflow
ecosystem
so i mentioned before that we're trying
to standardize
the interface for tensorflow and we're
really focusing on something called the
saved model format the save model gives
you the ability
to have your model generated in r or in
python
packaged up into a friendly format
that's a kind of a defined directory
structure that's also pretty human
readable there's a proto
um some weights uh you know like some
some additional metadata associated with
the model
and you can take that and you can put it
in a cellular device you can put it
on like an m m-series embedded device
you can use it in a browser as a web
application
or pretty much anything else we've also
started built work on
improving our c plus plus api for
tensorflow you'll be seeing
an announcement about that in a couple
of months
with uh sort of the road map for the c
plus plus inference api
as well as the c plus plus api for
training
and the the idea is that all of it is
focused around this concept of a saved
model and again
um with your r code you can generate
this as an output and deploy your models
anywhere that you could with a
tensorflow python model
we've also integrated tensorboard into
jupyter notebooks
jupyter notebooks have support for r of
course if you wanted to use an r
kernel or you can also use tensorboard
within rstudio i believe
with built-in performance profiling both
for gpu and for tpu
and so under the hood autograph and tf
function i mentioned this a little bit
earlier but what they're doing
is even though we're giving you the
ability to do
eager computation um kind of
you know the you add numbers you get a
response that sort of thing
autograph and tf function um sort of
take whatever arbitrary python code
you've created
and they build a graph out of it so so
that means
that your your models even though
they're debuggable and they're easily
understandable when you need them to be
they're also hyper-performant if you
need to run them on accelerated hardware
or at scale
using tf distribute
so learning more like i said strongly
recommend
the tutorials in the blog posts on
rstudio.com
or tensorflow.orgstudio.com
the book sort of the canonical example
is
the the re-implementation of francoise
initial book with jj elaire
deep learning with r um and if you have
an idea for a tensorflow r
project that you would like to see
funded and you're a university student
or you know of a university student who
wants to get paid for doing open source
work
let me know and we can get it added to
the tensorflow google summer of code
project list
so i think um
that is the question that i have for all
of you today
um so how can our team better support
the needs of
of you guys and you know if you if you
want additional documentation if you
would like to have
sort of uh you know better a better
seepless plus api
to provide more efficient bindings just
let us know and we can discuss my
email is web page page spelled like my
name at google.com
because i hear web pages do pretty well
at google
and that is all um so thank you so much
questions thoughts
otherwise
so the most popular question probably is
not going to be a surprise
uh does google hire our data scientists
oh that's cool
so yes absolutely um so i i actually
uh when i got to google the first thing
i did was find out where our code was
being used
um like google has this thing called
code search
which is a massive monorepo
so you can access the code that's used
to create
you know like i said gmail hangouts
whatever
so if you want to find all of the easter
eggs and hangouts chat you can find it
or like create your own
um but yeah there's a ton of r
being used at google and many of the the
teams that are using
r are especially interested in in sort
of
transitioning from these uh more
traditional machine learning approaches
um to using deep learning and
so they hire our data scientists
definitely all around google
also statisticians and also uh
like i i know that kaggle
recently
had a had a data scientist who has since
migrated to go work on really nifty
natural language processing tools
um but she was one of the one of the
best
sort of r aficionados that i have met in
my career
so yes that was a long-winded answer to
a very short question
sorry but an interesting one thank you
so
um the ability to interpret models has
been in the news a lot
oh absolutely so there's a question are
there any plans to integrate deep
learning model interpretability methods
like
integrated gradients deep lift and or
smooth grad
as a functions in base tensorflow so i'm
not sure
about base tensorflow but i do know that
explainability is one of the things that
we are most
sort of most focused on for google as a
company
and then also for tensorflow as a
product so
for every machine learning model that we
roll out at alphabet
it has to go through an extensive review
process both for fairness and for
explainability
and we have a collection of tools that
are available to help with this
so fairness
[Applause]
people in ai research uh
it's a team um from uh
led by fernando villegas um but it
uh they they have a number of uh open
source
tools available for model
interpretability um
for for sort of explaining fairness uh
there's this great thing called the what
if tool that allows you to
understand what data even if you don't
necessarily notice that it could be
biased
is actually impacting your model results
if let me pull this up really quick and
the nice thing too is that it's
integrated
into tensorboard so if you want to be
able to use it with the arm models that
you've created
you would be able to do that both by
doing the facets deep dive
um as well as as comparing models and
comparing data points
so hopefully that helps answer the
question
um so the the answer i i guess the the
tl dr
is i don't know if we're going to put it
in base tensorflow
like if anything we're trying to get
stuff out of base tensorflow so it's
more performant
and it's less expansive and easier to
learn um but
it will uh all of these things are
certainly available as additional
packages
um that you can use in conjunction with
tensorflow
thank you and let's thank page one more
time one more round of applause
you